ترحيل اللاجئين من تركيا عنوان رئيسي
للحملات الانتخابيه لمرشحي الرئاسه رجب
طيب اردوغان ومنافسه كمالك الجدار اهله
والله
الرئيس التركي يطرح خطه لعوده اللاجئين
السوريين طواعيه ويعلنوا تمسكه بتواجد
اصحاب الكفاءات العاليه منهم
ثم منافسه بكمالك الجدار اوغلو فيتبنى
خطابا يرتكز على ترحينهم جميعا الى بلادهم
في عامين ويعلن ارقاما عن تعدادهم وصلت
الى عشره ملايين لاجئ لدينا هناك حوالي
ثلاثه مليون و400 الف سوريين هنا في تركيا
وهو رقم شككت فيه جهات رسميه عده في
البلاد فهل يقلق اللاجئ السوري من نتائج
الانتخابات
نزلنا الى منطقه الفاتح في اسطنبول
المعروف بكثافه التواجد العربي هناك لنعرف
الاجابه
يعني كل شيء عادي وكل شيء طبيعي وما في اي
شيء يعني ولو حتى فازت المعارضه يعني
حيقلعونا ما حيقلعونا من تصريحات المعارضه
بنشعر بخوف شديد
لانه نحن لاجئين عندهم في بلدهم يعني
ضيوفي بلدهم نتمنى انه ترجع سوريا مثل ما
كانت نرجع لبلدنا ولبيوتنا بالنسبه للخوف
من الانتخابات او شيء لا بد ان هو بس
موضوع زعل مو اكثر وصلنا لزمن صاروا او
صرنا نتهدد فيه بالرجعه لبلدنا لهالدرجه
صار الزمن سيئه يعني
انا عادي والله يعني لاني خايفان ولا شيء
اذا سقط مثلا اردوغان مثلا اكيد ما راح
نتقلع على سوريا هذا الخوف لازم يشيلوه
يعني من قلبهم يعني هذا الخوف اكيد نحن
خوف ما في خوف كسولين بالنسبه
بالنهايه تكلمنا نعرف انه
وحتى لو ما هو اصلا نجحوا بالانتخابات
يعني كنسبه كبيره من الشعب هم مع كسوري
نحن بننزل لحالنا اذا صار يعني ان شاء
الله حل صيام وهيك لمصلحه الشعب لمصلحه
السوريين ليش لا في احلى الواحد من بلده
ينزل على بلده بيته واهله
[موسيقى]